THE SUBPOENA BEING THE FIRST BIG
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
UPDATE.
>>> JOINING US NOW, MICHAEL
COHEN, THE FORMER PERSONAL
ATTORNEY AND 76ER FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
MICHAEL, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU, ALISYN.
>> LET'S START THERE, THAT'S
WHAT WE HEARD THIS MORNING FROM
ALISSA R. GRIFFITH, THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SHE SAID THAT TEAM TRUMP HAS
BEEN PROVIDING AND SUPPLYING
LAWYERS FOR THE STAFFERS WHO ARE
TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE, INCLUDING
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON BEFORE SHE
CHANGED TO HER OWN LAWYER.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
PERSONAL ATTORNEY, WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THAT PRACTICE?
>> YES, THIS IS PART AND PARCEL
FOR THE DONALD TRUMP GAME PLAN.
WHAT YOU DO IS YOU PAY FOR THE
LAWYERS.
THAT WAY THE LAWYERS REALLY
AREN'T DEDICATED TO THE CLIENT.
THEY'RE DEDICATED TO THE GUY
PAYING THE BILL, WHICH, OF
COURSE, IS TEAM TRUMP.
THE REASON THEY'RE DOING THAT IS
TO KEEP YOU ON MESSAGE THE
SECOND YOU DEVIATE FROM THE MA
EDGE THAT DONALD WANTS, YOU GET
CUT OFF.
SOMETHING HE DID TO ME AS WELL.
I AM VERY PROUD OF HER FOR
REALIZING EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING
ON HERE AND MAKING THE DECISION
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE TRUMP
PAID-FOR COUNSEL AND MOF TO HER
OWN.
SOME, AN ATTORNEY THAT WILL NOW
HAVE HER BEST INTEREST IN.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SHE
TESTIFIED TO WAS THE THINGS THAT
SHE SAW AND HEARD, INCLUDING
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
OUTBURSTS.
SO LET ME PLAY A PORTION OF THAT
FOR YOU.
>> MR. TRUMP TEN THEN USED HIS
FREE HAND TO LUNGE TOWARDS BOBBY
ENGEL AND WHEN MR. ORANATO
RECOUNTED THE STORY, HE MOTIONED
TOWARDS CLAVICLES.
THERE WERE TIMES IN MY TENURE
THAT I WAS KNOWN OF HIM THROWING
DISHES OR FLIP AC TABLE CLOTH.
>> DOES THAT SEEM LIKE DONALD
DONALD TRUMP?
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN HIM TAKE A
BURGER AND THROW IT AGAINST THE
WALL, I'VE SEEN HIM THROW
THINGS, NEWSPAPERS, A MAGAZINE,
SOME PAPER, BUT I'VE NEVER SEEN
HIM THROW CATCH-UP.
IS IT POSSIBLE?
SURE.
BUT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT,
LOOK, EVERYBODY WHO SAW THOSE
JANUARY 6th HEARINGS WILL SAY
THE SAME THING.
THIS WAS A GREAT, GREAT, THIS
WAS JUST A GREAT FLY ON THE WALL
PRESENTATION.
I MEAN, IT'S LIKE GOING TO SEE
"TOP GUN MAVERICK."
YOU WALKED OUT AND FELT GOOD
THAT FINALLY SOMETHING WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
THIS WAS THE IMPETUS FOR MERRICK
GARLAND TO DO SOMETHING BY THE
DOJ.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE TESTIMONY
IS THAT IT'S ALL HEARSAY.
AS IT RELATES TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> I MEAN, NOT EXACTLY SO.
SOME OF THE SHE ACTUALLY HEARD,
SHELVES IN THE ROOM OF IT.
>> IT'S HEARSAY, OUT OF COURT
STATEMENTS ASSERTED THEREIN.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
HEARSAY.
DONALD WILL SAY, I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
I NEVER TOLD ANY ONE OF THESE
PEOPLE TO DO IT.
SHOW ME IF YOU THINK I DID SAY
IT, SHOW ME ONE PIECE OF PAPER
THAT I HAPPENED WROTE.
SHOW ME AN E-MAIL, A TEXT
MESSAGE, SHOW ME A VOICEMAIL.
DONALD TRUMP LEARNED FROM THE
REST.
I'M REFERRING TO ROY COHEN, HAVE
NO FINGERPRINTS ON ANYTHING.
ALL OF THESE AC COLIGHTS AROUND
HIM, EACH AND EVERY ONE IS IN
JEOPARDY.
>> ONE IN THE SECRET SFT, SHE
HEARD THE STORY ABOUT HIM
LUNGING FOR THE WHEEL OF THE
BEAST AS THEY CALLED, THE
PRESIDENT, LIMO AND THE
CLAVICLES, THAT'S NOW BEING
DISPUTED BY THE SECRET SERVICE.
DOES THAT 10U7BD LIKE THE DONALD
TRUMP YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH, SO, LOOK, I'VE NEVER
SEEN OR HEARD THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN IN A PHYSICAL
ALTERCATION.
I'M NOT TALKING AS AN ADULT.
EVEN AS A KID.
SO THE FACT, YOU COULD REST
ASSURED THAT WHILE THIS WAS
GOING ON, IF HE REALLY WANTED TO
GO TO THE CAPITOL, HE WOULD BE
THIS IRATE.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
DOES THAT MEAN HE WOULD LUNGE AT
A SECRET SERVICE AGENT, GO TO
GRAB THE STEERING WHEEL?
I'M NOT SURE.
BUT THAT'S DOUBLE HEARSAY.
SHE HEARD IT FROM SOMEBODY ELSE
WHO HAD HEARD IT.
AGAIN, THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE
THE NAIL IN THE COFFIN THAT WE
ALL ARE LOOKING FOR IN ORDER TO
SEE DONALD WITH HIS HAND BEHIND
HIS BACK AND HIS COTTON CANDY
FLOPPING IN THE WIND.
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE.
THE BAD PART ABOUT THAT
TESTIMONY IS WHAT IT DOES, IT
GIVES DONALD.
I KNOW THE PLAYBOOK BETTER THAN
ANYONE.
I WAS INVOLVED IN WRITING IT.
THEY'RE GOING TO USE THAT
TESTIMONY, ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
DISPROVEN TO ATTEMPT TO DISPROVE
EVERY SINGLE STATEMENT THAT
CASSIDY MADE AND THAT'S A SHAME.
BUT THEY WILL USE THAT AS A YOU
KNOW A MEANS TO DISCREDIT HER.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HEARD DURING THAT TESTIMONY,
DURING THAT HEARING I SHOULD SAY
IS CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY
TALKING ABOUT INTIMIDATION THAT
SOME WITNESSES HAVE BEEN SUBJECT
TO.
SHE SAID THINGS THAT BASICALLY
THEY GET PHONE CALLS THAT SAY
THINGS LIKE AS LONG AS AS I
CONTINUE TO BE A TEAM PLAYER,
THEY KNOW I'M ON THE RIGHT TEAM.
I'M DOING THE RIGHT THING.
I WANT TO STAY IN THE GOOD
GRACES OF TRUMP WORLD.
THEY WERE REMINDED WITNESSES A
COUPLE TIMES, TRUMP DOES READ
TRANSCRIPTS.
I THINK YOU MAY KNOW A THING OR
TWO ABOUT THOSE TACTICS.
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, LET ME
SEE, HE DOES NOT READ IT.
HE HAS SOMEBODY READ IT AND GIVE
HIM THE BULLET POINTS TO IT.
BUT I RECEIVED THE IDENTICAL
TYPE OF COMMUNICATIONS.
THOSE WERE BY BOB COSTELLO,
DIRECTLY AFTER THE RAID ON MY
HOME HOTEL LAW OFFICE AND SAFETY
DEPOSIT BOX, WHERE THEY WOULD
SAY, OUR FRIEND LOVES YOU, STAY
LOYAL, STAY THE COURSE.
HE'S GOT YOUR BACK.
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
REGARDED AND THESE ARE ALL YOU
KNOW PLAYS THAT HE HAD LEARNED
EARLY ON IN HIS LIFE FROM PEOPLE
LIKE ROY COHN.
IT IS A MOB-STYLE SCENARIO,
WHERE YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THESE FOLKS STAY IN YOUR ORBIT
AND IF, IN FACT, THAT YOU STEP
OUT OF THE ORBIT, UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE THERE THAT
ARE GOING TO POTENTIALLY DO SOME
PRETTY BAD THINGS TO YOU.
NOW WHAT DONALD WILL SAY IS I
DON'T WANT WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE,
THAT THEY'RE DOING -- I DIDN'T
TELL ANYBODY TO DO IT.
WHO ILL THAT MAY BE TRUE, HE
ALSO DIDN'T INDIVIDUALLY TELL
ANYONE TO SPECIFICALLY RAID THE
CAPITOL.
BUT HE SAID IT IN A WHAT I THAT
PEOPLE TAKE IT AS THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE OUT THERE.
I RECEIVED MORE HATE MAIL, MORE
HATE E-MAILS AND SO ON YOU CAN
IMAGINE.
SOME OF THE MOST VIAL THINGS YOU
CAN SAY TO ANOTHER HUMAN BEING
FROM MY RELIGION TO MY CHILDREN
TO MY LIFE TO MY WIFE'S, TO MY
FAMILY.
THEY ARE JUST VIAL THINGS THAT
ARE SAID BY PEOPLE WHO THINK
THAT THEY'RE DOING SOME TYPE OF
A SERVICE TO DONALD WHEN, IN
FACT, YOU KNOW, IT'S HER LIFE,
MY LIFE, ANYBODY'S LIFE WHO
STEPS FORWARD AND YOU KNOW AND
TALKS TRUST TO POWER.
YOU PUT YOURSELF INTO THAT SPOT
AND A LOT OF THE ACTIONS THA